vous saviez qu'on a fait rouler les bus
à haut niveau de service et que par
conséquent il y avait un coup à ce
niveau là à payer
il fallait un p3 troch j'ai annoncé
qu'on progrès la seule conséquence ont
été satisfaits et tout le monde avoue du
deuxième ou troisième chose c'est que je
n'annonce le tcsp baoulé le 13 août le
tirage ou 2018 dans la matinée là où je
suis a brisé le moment venu de façon
précise pourquoi
tokyo 15 en accord avec le maire le fort
le pauvre monsieur didier n'a guère
puisque vous savez que à cette période
il voit la bouche des yoles et la
cohésion et les canaux vont qui peut
arriver à faire deux fois donc il m'a
demandé de communes à caen doit pouvoir
pas bhl commandes il précisé comme un
des leurs tout simplement pour lui
permettre d'inverser son sont
comédiennes sont arrêtés de circulation
en harmonie avec nous donc c'est cette
technique les mêmes et tout